hello and welcome to this video playing
me haga rich & goo & from the gutter
ready gambit is playing this kind of
setup for a long time no what's wrong
with these sex okay I can can lead to
some closed Catalan school let me play
the form now it takes us ha I'm not
really an expert on those move orders
[Music]
yeah I was just thinking you might just
do this let's see if I can open this up
if it feels the way or the speed with
what is playing is like the suit pain
but this seems to be something known but
I can just take it may be okay I can
take the rook can take the rook of
course yeah this is it this is kind of
typical this move you know I don't
really know about this specific position
what he's doing is certainly quite risky
it's a very risky way to gain some sharp
playing in this Catalan position
kiss my cheek on d 593 seems like the
quickest way to develop yeah let's do it
it's like with the quickest way to to
develop him coming with 95 with the
tempo and I I don't know does this I
don't think it's particularly important
that my light squared Bishop is missing
yeah so I can take you five now or
taking b5 he's got rupee aight i guess
but a guy can take in check ok let's do
that first so yeah that was kind of it
was expected so what to do lucky for you
should be three books you've won this
kind of thing or bishop as3 actually you
might take i think i have to do this
first and so after Bishop as3 if you
take so i can check with the Queen I
need to I can stop it from castling and
would be really nice there should be
three is the most visually 6 i'm sorry
is the most obvious move in this
position
so we have Bishop e3 again it's the
obvious move I don't know if it's the
best move so we cannot castle now and my
direct threat is screened e6 okay 26 you
will take probably it seems difficult
from this position grabbing twice on d5
is definitely risky and this is probably
a nice way of describing it yeah this is
this is the move that I actually
expected giving the pawn back if I thick
with the night he will castle and have
some some kind of position Queen check
is possible Bishop d7 then
you
I don't know there's something better I
would definitely like to check Madame
Chiang let's let's let's play we should
be seven I can take on before with the
Queen I don't know if this pawn is
meaning much
so I have 495 starting with this is
probably okay a 5 verse 9 27 and the
night is pretty strong
hmm I did not I thought that would just
lead into a big big pin isn't that
threatening 93 now so 93 will win the
air horn very likely I again the ad just
touches to it yeah nite nite b5 somewhat
and 36 I can't bring the King up as long
as you cannot move the pawn everything
is cool
[Music]
[Music]
okay that probably was not the absolute
best technical play but it still looks
nice check should check with okay I
don't don't really see something bad
happening here time morning time is a
problem just as I say I don't see
anything bad happening I got the time
warning
[Music]
what's the deal i am i overlooking
something check check check
check check check check check check
check check check check black resigned
oh I was a tough one are the tough one
yeah I think it's not a pretty good
opening result i don't i don't really
know the theory am i normally I go b3
yeah but I thought before why not yeah I
go into a Catalan but um yeah this is it
feels very risky stuff here for black
but I don't know the theory then you
wants to do this but this this yeah that
looks pretty good actually as a six
doesn't work now okay so be three cakes
this
g5 know hey that wasn't on my radar 95
whoopee ain't okay so I'm quite happy
with us now this yeah I don't know 93
given by the engine that's yeah maybe
maybe the engine is just basically
taking on a ada nokri takes wins whoa
wins and okay it should be sadness but
should be three there's no dough decent
move here right ok and then 93 is even
stronger but this is also i think
dangerous at least a six and ten the
engine claims a win Queen f3 oh that's
nice Vanya that's a nice move stopping
bishop moves moves by that Bishop to
play in place like that check and Queen
f3 is so we're strong move okay so I
played it like that big stakes and now
the computer wants to take on d5 but
this is definitely going to be quite
dangerous I also felt that is the
critical off but it feels very dangerous
yeah I don't know this would have been a
tough call which rich rook and I thought
about something like that and I felt
like this must be quite okay I Roxy and
I Roxy one that's cute Queenie 736 a6
nice again he went be formed check and
then I grabbed the pawn
yeah this is probably a lot better to
winning but it wasn't John check this on
a chatline Chang unloaded and so
important I don't think so actually I
think here chattin gets very yeah this
is finite and it's not difficult to play
which as important as I had no time
[Music]
chatter keeping nice giant piece on the
board is better but this was easier to
play with no time okay thanks for
watching